hallo leute wir drehen jetzt wieder ein
neues video für euch heute zeigen wir
euch vokabeln rund um das thema ja was
eigentlich
ich weiß schon gar nicht mehr was ist
das
wir zeigen euch heute vokabeln rund um
das thema autos und autofahren los
geht's
[Musik]
wir beschreiben euch jetzt das auto wir
fangen mit der motorhaube an dass es
diese hier und schau mal rein was da so
alles drunter ist
in diesem behälter hier ist das
scheibenwischwasser in diesem behälter
ist das kühlwasser dort drüben ist die
batterie hier ist der motor und hier
wird das öl nachgefüllt und kontrolliert
das ist die windschutzscheibe und das
sind die scheibenwischer das ist einer
der seitenspiegel
das ist eine forderte und das ist das
schiebedach
hier haben wir einen reifen eine felge
und den tankdeckel wo man dann entweder
benzin oder diesel tankt das ist die
antenne
das ist die heckscheibe und das ist der
kofferraum das ist die stoßstange
das ist ein scheinwerfer und das ist ein
blinker
jetzt fahren wir mal eine runde als
allererstes immer der sicherheitsgurt
immer schön am schneiden damit dass es
erst dann starten wir den wagen bei
einem dieselmotor muss man vorglühen
das heißt man wartet jetzt sind die
lampen aus und startet den motor dann
muss ich die fußbremse lösen
und es kann losgehen
[Musik]
wir bieten jetzt nach rechts ab also in
blinker an ihm kommt keiner
los geht's
[Musik]
es ist heiß daher ist ein bisschen
fahrtwind immer gut
[Musik]
so jetzt müssen wir einen parkplatz
finden und einparken
jetzt zeigen wir euch den innenraum vom
auto wir haben hier das lenkrad die hupe
die verschiedenen anzeigen hier ist zum
beispiel die geschwindigkeitsanzeige die
tankanzeige temperaturanzeige der
kilometerstand und eine uhr
hier haben wir die gangschaltung das
autoradio
hier kann die lüftung kontrolliert
werden
das warnblinklicht und hier kann man die
heckscheibenheizung anstellen
es handelt sich bei diesem auto um einen
automatik wagen
daher gibt es hier nur das gaspedal und
die bremse dieser hebel ist gleichzeitig
der blinker die scheibenwaschanlage und
das fernlicht das ist der beifahrersitz
mit anna kopfstütze und das ist der
rückspiegel so wir haben ein paar
besorgungen gemacht jetzt wieder
auspacken den rückwärtsgang und
rückwärts ausparken
[Musik]
und weiter geht die tour
das war unsere episode rund ums
autofahren
wir hoffen ihr habt einiges gelernt wenn
ihr jetzt noch mehr vokabeln lernen
wollt dann probiert doch mal unsere app
sie länger aus dort könnt ihr unter
anderem eure aussprache trainieren
ihr nehmt euch selbst auf und vergleicht
euch dann mit einem muttersprachler
so könnt ihr eure aussprache schritt für
schritt verbessern
bis bald
[Musik]